at least five people dead another 48
injured after a man drove his suv into a
christmas parade the man had a long
criminal record drugs
battery domestic abuse he was charged
just last july with two counts of
reckless endangerment and possession of
a dangerous weapon as a convicted felon
but he was released on 500 bail last
february then he was charged again just
a couple of weeks ago with resisting or
obstructing an officer bail jumping
recklessly endangering safety disorderly
conduct and battery connected to
domestic abuse
then
he was released just six days after that
on a thousand dollar bond then he struck
again
now five people are dead
dozens are injured
this is
criminal justice reform in practice
this is
compassion
this is the compassion being peddled not
just by democrats but by many
republicans as well i'm michael nolisis
michael mosher
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from squeezyplays
who says the only way to end the endless
cycle of sins of the father is
forgiveness but who needs forgiveness
when you can destroy someone's life for
clout right we talked about this
yesterday i mentioned this great thinker
renee gerard who has this idea
that culture begins with a sort of
founding murder cain and abel romulus
and remus and the the definition of
human culture is memetic rivalry where
we just kind of mimic one another and it
gets worse and worse and worse and the
only way to end it is by scapegoating
somebody or with a unanimous ritual
killing or with this kind of violence
this war of all against all until
christianity christianity comes in and
says no we're not going to do that
anymore we're going to take the side of
the victim and what does the left say
nope no thanks and we all do it see we
even we all scapegoat we're all part of
that and when we're scapegoating we're
not even aware that we're scapegoating
very very insightful comment i'm going
to remember that comment one way that i
cherish all of my memories is with
legacy box legacy box is the best way to
preserve your past it's very simple you
have your photos and your home movies
and your tapes you send them in to
legacy box they will hand digitize all
of them to protect them against flood
and fire and old father time they will
send this back to you on the cloud on a
dvd on a thumb drive so it's
future-proofed forever you'll also get
your physical media back so you'll still
have those memories but while those
physical media will degrade over time
the digital ones will last forever it
happened to me that a beloved family
member who had died
i i lost all of the pictures of her i
lost them all and i was devastated by
this because i hadn't sent them into
legacy box
i didn't have the the didn't even know
about legacy box at that point then i
found some more instantly sent them in
it was so easy i got all my pictures
back and now they're future proofed
forever legacy box is giving our
listeners their best deal of the year
during their black friday event visit
legacybox.com knowles to save an
unbelievable 65
with limited quantities ready to ship
this deal will go fast go to
legacybox.com
knowles for 65 off legacybox.com
knowles
the
criminal who killed those people and
injured so many more people was out on
on a thousand dollar bond he he
shouldn't have been out on the bond
obviously he shouldn't have been out
even the last time because he got out on
a bail for the last charges he's a
career criminal he's a thug he should
have been rotting away in prison but
we have calls for
criminal justice reform we have calls
for leniency we have calls openly to
abolish prisons
and we're told this is compassionate
it's very wrong to lock up dangerous
criminals it's it's wrong and it's
racist somehow and it's and it's
mean-spirited and it's cruel and so
we've got to let them out and because
the compassionate thing is to let five
people be struck by an issue well i'm
sorry dozens of people struck by an suv
five killed and many many more injured
even the d.a in milwaukee county john
chisholm now admits the bail was a
little too low they were a little too
compassionate don't you think
quote the state's bail recommendation in
this case was inappropriately low
in light of the nature of the recent
charges and the pending charges against
this guy
says john chisholm the milwaukee d.a
whoopsie daisy
yep oops it was a little too low ah
yeah maybe it should have been two
thousand dollars oops whoopsie
uh that's it that's it that now
no i don't i don't think that's it i
think that first of all this guy john
chisholm should resign
or should be chased out of office
and i think that we need to take a
moment here and pause and figure out
what got us into this mess in the first
place i'm not just throwing blame on
everyone obviously the guy who drove the
suv is
the person primarily at fault here he's
the one who committed the crime
but how was he permitted to commit that
crime
through gross negligence
through criminal negligence if you ask
me of our law enforcement of our really
of our elected officials
and and of the people of milwaukee who
voted for these people and who voted for
this kind of stuff criminal justice
reform we've got to be compassionate
it's not even just democrats i want to i
want to do my best to mitigate
scapegoating the left here and
scapegoating the democrats the
republicans did this too trump peddled
this stuff you know i love trump i voted
for trump twice big supporter of trump
but he peddled this stuff remember the
first step act
which i referred to at the time and
still do as the jailbreak bill we were
told it's somehow deeply conservative to
spring criminals from the clink
how is that conservative
even the republicans even right-wing
conservative republicans bought into
this lie that we have an
over-incarceration problem in the united
states we got crime spiking crime is
going through the roof especially
violent crime
up to and including murders
but obviously we don't have an
over-incarceration problem we have an
under-incarceration problem
when crime's gone up you have an
under-incarceration problem okay
so how did we get here how did we get to
the point where obviously the libs were
leading the way on it but how do we get
to the point where even the right
wingers were peddling this kind of
insanity that leads to such horrific
results well
here is here is the logic
peddled by articulated by rashida talib
she is i guess she's sort of the george
harrison of the squad aoc is mccartney
ilhan omar is john lennon
ayanna presley is ringo she's kind of
the least important member
and so i guess where she had to leave is
the george harrison of the squad she
just sat down on with axios
and was questioned about her bill
supporting the emptying
of prisons here's her argument
in 2020 you endorsed
the breathe act which is a series of
proposals to transform america's
criminal justice system
and create quote a road map for prison
abolition
the breathe act proposes emptying
federal detention facilities within 10
years
to what extent have you wrestled with
any potential downsides of releasing
into society every single person who's
currently in a federal prison yeah again
i think that everyone's like oh my god
we're gonna just release everybody
that's not what i'm saying yeah but did
you see how many people are mentally ill
that are in prison right now no i know
but the act that you so
actually says release everyone but in 10
years but think about it who are
releasing if they were like human
traffickers oh i know child sex so
people say do you mean that you don't
actually support that because you
endorse them no i endorse the breathe
act in looking at federal
the policies and how we incarcerate
absolutely but it says
you cannot you cannot
you cannot just blankly say oh look she
wants that's not what i'm saying but
that's like in plain text
that is what you're saying you got to
give it to jonathan swan over at axios
he is a pretty dogged interviewer and
he's he's basically fair i assume he's
on the left but he's basically fair and
he obviously he's much much more
intelligent than rashida talib who is
not the brightest bulb in the pack so
she endorsed this bill that
literally said empty out the federal
prisons and so he says do you really
support emptying it out like child
rapists and mother killers and all
psychos and all these people and she
said no that's not what it says and he
says no it's literally what it says and
she goes no but think about how many
mentally ill people there are
so
oh so you so you're admitting that you
want you're saying the reason we need to
let everyone out is because they're
mentally ill even though there are
plenty of criminals who are not mentally
ill and the ones who are mentally ill
i'm not sure we want them on the streets
either if they're if they're criminally
insane and he says okay so you do want
to let them all out she goes no but it's
not it's not fair to say we're going to
let them all out it's going to take 10
years okay well what about in 10 years
well no jonathan you're not and she she
can't keep up and so she's just got this
smile on her face and she's saying
things that don't make any sense and
he's giving her the out he's saying okay
so you
we're agreeing you don't want to let
every single person she won't
take the out
what i'm saying is look at
who's in prison now
no look at the folks that are mentally
ill they have substance abuse problems
i'm not disagreeing with you that there
are people who yeah so why aren't you
asking me about them you're asking me
about the criminal human traffickers and
others that should i'm trying to
understand
your proposal is so sweepy it does it
does release everyone and what i'm
trying to say within 10 years and
obviously there's a process of looking
at how can we get away from mass
incarceration
and move towards care first what i'm
trying to understand because it is such
a sweeping concrete proposal do you
believe that there are still categories
of people who should be behind there are
absolutely
folks
that
i don't under you know i don't know
because right now the way the prison
system was supposed to be like
rehabilitatory you know it's supposed to
be rehabilitation right right no really
that's how they i think that yeah i
don't think there's any rehabilitation
happening right now for those that might
actually have you know again a majority
there's so many that have mental health
issues
she can't say it she gets so close to
saying it
and she's saying why stop talking to me
about the child rapists let's just talk
about the poor drug addicts and he says
right no but the the issue with your
bill is not exactly the important it's
not mostly the poor drug addicts it's
the what about the child rapists and the
mother killers and the serial killers
and the psychopaths you're going to let
them out too
well no but you're not and then finally
he says will you at least admit that
there are some people
jeffrey dahmer i don't just some people
who should be in prison and she goes
well i will admit
that there are some people yeah yeah who
and we need to look at and she won't do
it she won't do it because her logic is
not a single person should be in prison
she says the purpose is rehabilitation
first of all that's a purpose of
criminal justice but it's not the
primary purpose the primary purpose of
criminal justice is retribution you
commit a crime you are punished to
satisfy justice
a second effect would be rehabilitation
it's very important but rehabilitation
is not the primary purpose because you
need to commit a crime first plenty of
people need rehabilitation who haven't
committed crimes we can't just start
sending them to prison deterrence would
be another another reason but deterrence
is not the primary purpose
otherwise you just make an example out
of anybody but there's a higher
threshold you've got to commit a crime
and then you send them there to satisfy
justice and there are other reasons to
do it as well and what i i don't want to
just say that this woman is an idiot or
is her moral lens is completely wrong
she is
making this very same argument that we
were talking about earlier about
victimhood about memetic rivalry to use
the technical term she is trying to take
the side of the victim and she's saying
the victim in this case are the people
who were failed by society who grew up
in bad homes who had bad examples and
yes they went to a life of crime but
they're victims too sure and as a result
of that myopic view
she is ignoring
the other victims of the criminals
now you don't want to become a victim
you want to protect yourself and your
family which is why i recommend you
check out ring you all know about the
ring doorbell i've been talking about it
for years it's this great doorbell where
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your doorstep whether you're in the
house
at the office on a beach somewhere a
really terrific product well did you
know ring also has a powerful alarm
ring alarm is this incredible affordable
home security system you can easily
install it yourself even i can install
it it's a lot cheaper than the other
companies
what they charge for one month you can
get an entire year of ring alarm with
professional monitoring
well right now for the best deals of the
year head on over to ring.com
knowles
i'm on the road a lot okay sometimes i'm
traveling with sweet little elise and
cute little baby june sometimes i'm
alone either way i feel
safe i feel confident i feel secure
thanks to ring it's very very important
to protect yourself this holiday season
deck the halls walls doors and windows
with the best deals of the year on the
award-winning ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles to get a great deal on a ring
alarm security kit today that is
ring.com
knowles
joe biden
as the head of the democrat party
doesn't want any part of this
issue in wisconsin of this attack this
that left five people dead and and over
40 people injured he doesn't want to
talk about it he doesn't want to get
into it because it exposes problems in
the left's agenda take a listen
yesterday he was he was giving some
remarks and he knew he had to address it
a little bit but he said i don't want to
get into it before the facts are out
before i begin
i want to comment on the tragedy that
occurred last night during the holloway
the holiday parade in wisconsin
while we don't have all the facts and
details yet we know this morning
that five families in waukesha
are facing fresh grief
of a life without a loved one at least
40 americans are suffering from injuries
some of them in critical condition
an entire community is struggling
struggling to cope with the horrific act
of violence he doesn't want to talk
though until the facts come out he's
certainly not going to talk about how
the attacker appears to be a leftist who
made a lot of left-wing social media
posts and he's not going to talk about
how he was out on bail and all that he's
not going to talk about any of that he
doesn't want to jump to any conclusions
joe biden
put video of kyle rittenhouse into a
campaign ad and called him a white
supremacist
completely baselessly forget about
waiting for the facts to come out he was
kyle renthouse was just exonerated by a
court
but but in this case joe biden wants to
wait because he knows how bad this looks
for them
this is this is what's so difficult to
understand about wokism
wokism is we think of it as
anti-christian or anti-conservative or
anti-american in a way though
it's just
it's it's too too christian it's too
american it's too
it's too compassionate right it's not
that it's a vice running freely it's
that it's a virtue running freely the
woke-ism is
is trying to out-christian the
christians this is why you'll you'll
very often see people on the left who
don't believe in christianity who don't
go to church you don't believe in jesus
they will they'll attack christians and
they'll say you hypocritical christians
you don't really believe what you say
you don't really understand the bible
you don't really follow jesus i mean i
don't either but you especially don't
i'm more i'm gonna out christian the
christians
i'm i'm going to out-compat i'm and what
they do is they take
one of the if not the central
uh anthropological feature of
christianity taking the side of the
victims that god himself in the passion
is a victim and takes the side of the
victims
and you know
destroys this kind of
unanimous scapegoating mob violence on
the cross right he destroys satan on the
cross
they they take that
and they point to any instance where a
christian has ever done anything wrong
and it's a fallen world so every all
christians have done something wrong and
they say yes see you're not you're
hypocrites you're you're not really
living up to your standards we're going
to take that com compassion we're going
to take that side of the victim and
we're going to divorce it from
christianity that's not going to work do
you know what and what ends up happening
you just end up
scapegoating other people you just end
up
being cruel to other people
so in this case
you are being cruel to
the victims of this killer in wisconsin
to the victims
of crime or you know at the at the
broader social level you're saying look
we're going to take the side of the
victims black
people and women
and so we're going to scapegoat white
men white men are going to be the cause
of all of the problem they can't get out
of it the only way you can get out of
that is with god he that this is this is
the
essence of christianity it actually
takes god mankind is not able to
overcome this kind of thing on his own
and this is why all of the attempts to
recreate christianity in the modern
world without god or
humanitarianism woke-ism liberalism
progressivism whatever ism they're all
bound to failure and they're all going
to make all the same mistakes
that the pagan world made before
christianity
pervaded the world in the first place
so by good old compassion at joe biden
he's going to keep his mouth shut about
wisconsin you know because he knows how
bad it looks for him democrats
are fleeing joe biden
even the
would-be future governor of texas
beethoven
is fleeing joe biden he was on cnn
he was asked do you want the president
to come campaign for you he says uh no
thanks
the recent poll shows though that just
35 percent of texans approve of his
performance would you like the president
to come and campaign with you this
campaign in texas is not going to be
about joe biden it's not going to be
about donald trump it's not going to be
about anyone from outside of our state
this is going to be about the people of
texas and what the people of texas
want and i told you they want the big
things like jobs great schools and
making sure everyone can see a doctor
but they also want to see some
competence in their government does that
mean that you would prefer that he not
come
based on what you just said it means
that i'm focused on texas and on my
fellow texans those are the people most
important to me there's there's no
politician there's no other person from
outside of this state who can help to
change the course of this election for
better or for worse
so first of all credit to the cnn lady
for pushing beto on the point she says
hey beto
do you want biden to come help you and
he was like no look oh listen man
hell no i don't heck no no man i uh
because no this is going to be about the
people of texas and he gives this
ridiculous platitude which is
just a polite way of saying joe biden
please don't come here.
and she pushes him says hold on
are you saying you actively do not want
him to come and he says there's no
politician who could help us
that's not true
that's not true there are plenty of
non-texas politicians who are popular in
texas
who could come and help
i mean this happens in every single race
you always have politicians from out of
state flying in to help various
candidates not just in texas but all
over the country
unless the politician's not popular and
we know joe biden's not popular his
approval rating is about 38
even though he's basically a rock star
compared to kamala harris whose approval
rating is 27 or 28
lower than dick cheney after he shot the
guy in the face but joe biden's still
underwater in terms of his approval
rating and so beto doesn't want it
beto knows that joe biden will drag him
down
and
beto doesn't have very far to go he's
already lost two races his last two
races he lost for senate and for
president so he can't afford that
what are the democrats going to do
forget texas what are they going to do
in 2022 all around the country what are
they going to do in 2024
when joe biden
may be running may not be running when
his if his vice president is the one
running she's in an even worse position
they don't seem to have anyone on the
bench other than pete butterjudge who's
going to be away on paternity leave
you know and no one's even going to miss
him when he's away
so the republicans are in a very strong
position right now
but don't worry
for the democrats out there listening to
this show right now do not worry about
the strong position the republicans are
in
they will find a way to clutch defeat
from the jaws of victory
they will
trust you can trust the republicans to
do that you can almost always trust
republicans to make at least the
republican leadership to make the exact
wrong
decision story out from nate hochman at
national review
he just had a great piece on this
the gop is going trans
yes the gop is now a trans party
they are pushing something called the
fairness for all act
this is an all all-republican bill
that would make sexual orientation and
gender identity
a federally protected class
according to the civil rights act
now in return what the gop would get
would be certain carve outs for the
right to discriminate you know against
those things for religious institutions
for instance but no one really thinks
that's going to hold up in court anyway
so this is
not the republicans compromising there
aren't any democrats who support this
bill
the the republicans who are pushing it
are saying well this is our version of
the equality act and we're going to
avoid the worse equality but there are
no democrats even agreeing to this so
it's just a it's just a surrender
it's just a concession to radical
transgender ideology
for no reason for no reason at all we
just won a governorship in virginia on
transgenderism
i'm saying that boys are not girls and
girls are not boys and you shouldn't let
boys into the girls room we just we just
deprived a blue state blue commonwealth
of a democrat governor and got a
republican governor in there on this
issue and these idiot republicans pardon
my blunt language i i hate to be so
direct
but they're
idiots or
they're moral either they're political
idiots and they can't make the right
calculation or they're moral idiots and
they don't see that actually boys are
not girls and girls are not boys i'm
like so angry i'm spilling my leftist
tears all over
i'm not going to get any of those
leftist tears today because of these
damned republicans who are who are
trying to clutch defeat from the jaws of
victory and who's supporting this
the house
gop caucus chairman elise stefanik
remember we had liz cheney in there and
she became a big lib and she started
shilling for nancy pelosi and so we got
elise stefanik and she was supported
actually by donald trump and by other
people and at the time i said watch out
for this one she's actually more liberal
than cheney on the political matters you
know on the partisan matters she tends
to side more with the republicans but
she's a big lib and it turns out she is
a big lib and there are 20 other
republicans who are supporting
transgenderism tone deaf rudderless with
republicans like this
who needs democrats
got to protect yourself folks one great
way to protect yourself
is with lifelock black friday is the
biggest shopping day of the year and
it's the biggest scam day of the year
okay it's one of the biggest ones some
of the most common scams include buying
a gift online that never arrives sellers
demanding payment with credit cards fake
shopping websites and fake delivery
notifications
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives good thing there's lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats for instance your
social security number for sale on the
dark web if they detect your information
has potentially been compromised they
will send you an alert now no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join right now and
save up to 25 percent off your first
year by going to lifelock.com
knowles k w l e s i know that a lot of
times people think oh they're not coming
after my identity they're not coming
after my data they are protect yourself
and that's a prevention is worth a pound
of cure go to lifelock.com
knowles for 25
off the daily wire shop is live and
ready for all of your extremely
important christmas needs you heard that
right daily wire merch is here head on
over to dailywire.com shop to check out
all of the brilliant collections such as
the shea fauche
designed teas for the alasko brandon
tailgate gear and so much more you can
also get my books there so this is a
great time of year to get the number one
stocking stuffer christmas present that
would be reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide this is my first
book
and it's
been a number one bestseller all over
amazon and it's sold a lot you can get
it for anywhere from like seven bucks up
to 15 bucks
and you can also get my other book
speechless controlling words controlling
mine so number one national bestseller
but if you head on over to the daily
wire shop right now if you're an all
access member you will get 20
off so head on over to dailywire.com
shop to get a little something for
everyone on your list who loves brandon
if you're not a member yet sign up right
now dailywire.com
subscribe use code dw35 you will get 35
off your membership and all the perks
you wouldn't get otherwise we'll be
right back with a lot more
it's so simple for the gop right now
it would be so simple
you've got democrats pushing this insane
these insane racial theories these
insane sexual theories telling parents
they have no right to educate their kids
telling parents that that that they have
no right to determine their kids medical
decisions whether it's the fauchy algae
or transiting the kid through mutilation
and surgery
it's so easy
all the republicans need to run on is
hey just be normal we're not gonna allow
the weird stuff and we're just gonna do
the normal stuff we're not going to let
criminals out of prison we're actually
going to have law and order and a
peaceful normal
good orderly society
and they just can't do that
look at what's going on in san francisco
right now in san francisco just a couple
nights ago
three stores were ransacked and emptied
out
by mobs of looters in the same night
so mob of people armed with hammers
entered a jewelry star store in hayward
which is about 35 miles from san
francisco at 5 25 p.m on sunday night
according to police take take a listen
to the operation
so you can see they just the bust in
there is about what four or five guys
and hoodies
oh no more than that
six seven eight nine ten okay there's
one in the back
so say about ten or a dozen guys with
hoodies they're smashing open cases of
jewelry and they're all
running out of their with
with the goods then in the nearby town
of walnut creek about 30 minutes outside
of san francisco 80 people wearing ski
masks and carrying crowbars robbed in
nordstrom on saturday night
uh they
uh broke into the store they pepper
sprayed and assaulted the employees they
grabbed a bunch of merch and they drove
away
eight people so this is i i want to be
precise it wasn't all in one night it
was over like a i don't know 36 hour 36
to 72-hour period eight people were
arrested friday after a louis vuitton
outlet was robbed in san francisco
multiple people broke the windows
emptied out the shop according to fox
the people who are weak on crime the
compassionate people the criminal
justice reform people they think this is
fine
they think it's fine to allow this to
happen
it's just stuff
the store owners they probably have
insurance
it's fine and they got their windows
smashed up a little and they you know
they're gonna have to close the shop for
you know a week or two but it's it's
fine
they actually a lot of these weak on
crime people think that this is just to
allow this to happen in particular
because the perps are black i'm not sure
if they were all black in all of the
instances but in the one that that we
have video for they're black
and so a lot of especially white
liberals
and a lot of people who are weak on
crime will say well this is because of
historic racism
because of slavery the these they have
to rob the jewelry store they have to
and it's wrong
there are the victims the people robbing
the jewelry store they're the real
victims
and the people who own the jewelry store
who might be black who might be
some other race but
they're you know they're evil
because they have they have property and
they've got their lives in order and so
really we should just let these
criminals off the hook and if they are
arrested let's let them out on a really
low bond and
if they commit more crime hey that's
just
that's that's justice huh
but it's not it's not i'll get to that
point that rashida talib mentioned when
she was talking about how we how she
doesn't really want to empty all the
jails but she does want to empty all the
jails and she said it's about
rehabilitation
sure
but in the jails they don't have enough
nice programs and they're not playing
enough games with the prisoners and so
they're not being rehabilitated
punishment
is rehabilitative
just
just punishment
including capital punishment by the way
hanging concentrates the mind the the
very fact of being punished for a crime
is
rehabilitative this is
not to bring up too many of my old dead
friends but this is what plato talks
about in gorgias
there's a great dialogue by plato and in
it socrates the character of socrates
explains that it is actually cruel not
to punish people for crimes
because it's not in their interest
because the people who are committing
these crimes have obviously disordered
desires and disordered habits and their
vices and they're basically on the road
straight to hell and it is an act of
mercy and compassion to punish them and
get them back on the straight and narrow
you think it's good for these robbers to
let them just continue in their life of
crime how do you think that's going to
end
how do you think that's going to end
it's going to end if they continue in
their life of crime they're either going
to get killed committing crime right
they're going to end up in some gang
shooting or some some burglary gone
wrong and or then they're going to get
killed or eventually they're probably
going to get
arrested and they're going to end up in
prison
or even if they get away with all of the
crimes in this life they're going
straight to the bad place once they die
they have souls they actually do have
souls and the care of their souls is
important there is nothing there there
is a false compassion
in letting these guys off the hook
because of whatever kooky racial or
historical theories you have
but it is a false compassion and it's
cruel
this is adam smith actually the uh you
know from from whom we get uh much of
our economic philosophy and the wealth
of nations adam smith said cruelty uh
mercy to the guilty is cruelty to the
innocent
it's a very stark way of putting it
but there is some truth to that
it's actually it is actually it's cruel
to the victims of these people it's
cruel to the shop owners it's cruel to
the future people that these criminals
are going to harm and it's cruel to the
criminals
themselves
speaking of mercy and charity
catholic university of america
seems to to really get this victim thing
a little wrong too they seem to have
abandoned
at least in in the artwork they're
putting on the walls
christianity their faith that's supposed
to animate the university for the rival
religion of wokism
this is from mary margaret olahan at the
daily signal
she pointed out that there are
icons on the walls of the catholic
university of america
that portrayed george floyd as christ or
christ as george george floyd
and the virgin mary as
as
george floyd's mother there's a painting
of a sort of pieta
and it's george floyd
blasphemous
sacrilegious
incredibly stupid
and and yet this is very popular
even in the woke christian circles i
just did an event at the catholic
university of america maybe a month ago
i was there with senator cruz they put
us in a green room and they had stations
of the cross you know the depictions of
the passion narrative all around the
room so i said that's nice and my
eyesight from far away it's not all that
great so i said oh that's nice and i
just sort of saw the blurs and my friend
liz wheeler was there she said michael
look closely at those pictures so i
zoomed in and all of the people christ
mary the apostles were all native
americans in headdresses i mean in just
you know in a
i thought this is blasphemous
this is sacrilegious
i don't have anything against indians
but
jesus is not an indian
he's not and
what all of this is trying to do
i'm trying to make the best argument i
can for these people is is they're
saying look jesus is just kind of an
idea
jesus is just like an idea and it's just
the idea of compassion for victims and
so if we portray jesus as
a native american that's that's fine it
doesn't matter if we portray jesus as a
as a black career criminal that's fine
of course
an important fact about jesus is that he
is sinless but no never mind he's a
black career criminal because it's just
the idea of being nice to victims but
it's not just the idea it's not
if christianity were merely the idea of
being nice to victims then it wouldn't
be worth very much
it wouldn't make a lot of sense it
certainly wouldn't have shaped
civilization it certainly wouldn't be
enough to overcome human nature
and sin and
death
if christianity means anything at all it
has to be a fact jesus has to be a real
guy he's got to actually look like
somebody
he's got to actually have features that
are not just the features of whoever you
want him to be
he had to live at a real time and die
and actually be resurrected
it has to have really happened
and
we can't do that before christianity
before judaism you had myth just myth
all these kinds of myths that maybe have
some basis in historical fact but
they're really just kinds of legends and
you tell themselves you tell norse myths
and greek myths and roman myths then you
have christianity which is not myth but
fact right it's a myth that happens to
be true and have really happened
and then
now in in what the left wants to be
post-christianity you just take these
kind of insights about christianity but
you make it myth again it's not just
myth
not compassionate at all it reveals
woke-ism for what it really is which is
an alternative religion a rival to
christianity
and not a not a rival to christianity
quite in the same way that paganism is
but a rival to cr as rene gerard says
arrival to christianity on its left
flank trying to be more christian
in christianity this stuff has real
effects the killer in in wisconsin
was allegedly
posting talking points from the woke
establishment media
heavy.com which is a fact-finding
website along with a number of other
journalists online andy noe pointed this
out early on highlighted posts
that the suspect in wisconsin had on his
social media accounts
that he allegedly had i know i have to
say whenever you're talking about a
story where all the facts have not been
totally sussed out you just have to say
allegedly like five hundred thousand
times so okay allegedly allegedly
allegedly
the posts
appeared to express
anti-christian sentiment
disdain for republican politicians and
conservative media i don't know if yours
truly was included but who knows you
know the conservative media broadly
and black nationalist rhetoric
okay and those are all
those are all big problems in america
those are all really big problems
and we don't
we don't think about that
we have we have big problems with
anti-muslim islamophobia that's a
terrible evil we need to root that out
of our society you hear all of the
establishment liberal outlets they'll
say we have to get rid of islam of
anti-semitism the same that's a little
bit weaker because the libs also hate
israel but still but anti-christianity
you're not allowed to mention that
disdain for republican politicians and
conservative media that is encouraged if
you ever
say anything
negative about a democrat politician
you're called an insurrectionist or
you're called a white supremacist or a
whatever a sexist racist whatever but
republicans that's totally fine and then
black nationalist rhetoric black
nationalism is a very bad thing
white white nationalism we're told is
the most evil thing in the history of
the world and we can never even mention
it but black nationalism gets a pass
malcolm x he's kind of cool right all
these guys they're really these are cool
guys
this reminds me of a problem that
republicans fall into as well
where everything we don't like is
fascism right you know fascism very very
evil the most evil thing in the world
nazism i guess is the most evil thing in
the world fascism close second they're
often the two are conflated
but communism is just fine communism
gets off the hook
if you wore a t-shirt with benito
mussolini's face on a college campus you
would almost certainly be expelled
if you wear a t-shirt with che guevara's
face on a campus
well that's the ordinary flow of things
now from the daily wire store you can
wear a t-shirt with uh faucet's face on
on on shayvara's body
but
that would be totally fine
the same way that republicans look at
antifa and they say antifa they say
they're anti-fascist but they are they
are fascist
they're not fascist
they're not they're communists and
they're anarchists
but they're not fascists
there are there are more bad things in
the world than fascism
but because fascism is a movement that
is sort of broadly on the right
that's the evil and you're you know
that's the worst thing possible
and because anarchism
generally is on the left and communism
certainly is on the left
that's totally fine
and we only in this
we scapegoat only the things that are on
the right
and we never look at the evils that are
on the left as well
we in the in our liberal culture
the other is always wrong you know to
use left wing language other ring we
always other the right wingers or the
christians or whatever but the liberal
establishment never looks in the mirror
and and takes stock of itself
you can't avoid politics i think what a
lot of the
squishes want to do
is they just want to back away
the squishes either want to use the
left-wing's preferred rhetoric
whether it's on gender or on race or on
you know everything that we don't like
is fascism or whatever they either want
to go along with the left
or they want to avoid it and they say
you know never mind i'm going to retreat
but you can't do that and actually this
is something that kyle rittenhouse is
dealing with right now now kyle
rittenhouse was exonerated in the court
of law but but
that's not the end the kid's 18 years
old what's he going to do for the rest
of his life this is the defining event
probably of his life so what is he going
to do now
and he's got two options
maybe three options
he can
become a conservative celebrity he
already is a sort of cause celeb so he
could he could become a conservative
celebrity he could just persevere and
live his life and do whatever he was
gonna do
or he can change his name and try to
start
again and his lawyer has
firm thoughts on the matter
and i'm not sure the lawyer is totally
right
kyle rittenhouse's lawyer
just went on tv was asked what are we
going to do about kyle rittenhouse what
is this kid's future and he says the
best thing this kid can do
change his name and start over again
i think there's a lot of people who want
to use kyle for their own means
i think the way the written house name
right now
um has trended on twitter and that's
what we live in as a twitter society
people want to use his name get it out
there so they can
get some publicity
um
i think it's cheap that's what i think
my advice would be to change his name
and start his life over
um he's very recognizable right now
there's a lot of people who i don't
think um
have his best interests at heart uh
and probably want to make him a symbol
of something i don't think he wants to
be
necessarily
um associated with
and once you give up
your name and your likeness
and you be
joining those causes i think a lot of
people will use you for their own
purposes and you won't be able to
control it we've had that talk with kyle
um and it's gonna be a fine line where
he decides to go
ultimately i hope he makes the right
choices you know i hope
i would think his life would be a lot
easier
um
being anonymous and going on with his
life as opposed to try and keep
some of his
fervent supporters happy
so
the part that this lawyer gets right is
yes they're going to be a lot of
vultures who want to use kyle for their
own purposes and that's bad and kyle
should be very careful and his parents
and his
lawyers should be careful not to let
that happen
but
he's even almost right that kyle would
probably have an easier life if he could
just change his name and become
anonymous and forget put this whole
thing behind him
first of all in our social media age
in our age of facial recognition in our
age of the internet where everything he
ever did is recorded for all time
does anyone really think that this kid
can just completely start over and
change his name and he'll just never
mind forget about kyle rittenhouse
i don't think that i don't think that's
ever going to happen and furthermore
changing his name
and starting this new life and trying to
run away from his identity and his past
implies that he did something wrong
implies that he was guilty
implies that he has something to be
deeply ashamed of
but he wasn't guilty he was exonerated
he was exonerated
and now he's being threat he's he was
exonerated in the court of law he's now
being just threatened by the mob the
left-wing mob
and what the lawyer is saying is
run away from the mob give the mob what
they want or run away from the mob or
turn that's a bad idea you can't do that
you can't i know it would be easy if we
lived in this ideal world where you
could just run away from your problems i
know that would be easy
but you can't that's a fool's errand
and it implies something that isn't true
namely that the kid
was guilty i don't think this is the
best advice
i do think there's a middle ground here
i don't think the kid
i think he should cash in
slander and libel lawsuits and i think
he should sue
every one of those outlets you know cnn
and the washington post and all the
people who smeared him you should sue
them into the ground like nick sandman
did but i agree i don't think he should
become a new celebrity i don't think you
should start campaigning for people i
don't think he should start his own
podcast i don't think he should do any
of that
a lot of a lot of people do that and you
can make easy money and it's very
attractive especially to young people
but the kid is
18 years old you shouldn't be doing that
that young people i know who got very
famous very young it has almost never i
don't know that in a single case it's
ever turned out well for them
so he shouldn't do that
but he shouldn't run from it either he
is kyle rittenhouse he went through a
lot he overcame a lot
he
was exonerated he won
don't
clutch a defeat from that victory
i don't think he i don't i don't even
think he can
i don't think you can run from your past
and your identity and from politics that
way there's a political lesson here too
a lot of conservatives the squishy nice
types they
they they want to fall into a kind of
quietism they just want to oh just tune
it out just never let's retreat to the
hills let's retreat to the farm and
never engage in pilot you can't do it
man
you can't do it
we have a country we live in a society
we're social animals we're the political
animal according to aristotle
you can't run away you might not care
about politics but politics cares about
you
you might not care about the culture but
the culture cares about you
speaking of people disappearing
i got to get to this before we go today
there was a chinese tennis star who just
metoo'd one of the members of the
communist party in china
she said that he sexually assaulted her
and pressured her and all sorts of
things and then she went missing she
just got disappeared and cnn was talking
about this on the air and as they
started talking about this they had a
video of their feed in china the feed in
china went blank that the communist
party censored
the the feed from cnn in china take a
listen
the wta says they simply don't have
evidence right now that punch y is not
being silenced that she is not able to
speak freely uh they they say none of
the proof that has been provided by
chinese state media john gives them any
comfort that she's that she's actually
in a position where her interests are
being best represented so will i want to
explain to our viewers what's happening
on our screen right now because
underneath your face they can see a box
which is the actual live feed of this
broadcast
in china
but it's all color bars and it went to
color bars the minute you started
talking so what's going on here
chinese sensors john i have lost count
over the last eight years here in asia
covering china of how many times cnn's
coverage of controversial issues has
been censored it used to go to straight
black now they've upgraded and they go
to color bars but nonetheless it is a
live real-time example of the censorship
that's happening in the mainland so
american state media was criticizing
chinese state media because the chinese
state media censored the story about how
they obviously disappeared this poor
girl i think she just appeared on some
video call but i don't buy it she's
obviously being controlled by the
chinese communist party and it's a
reminder the political aspect of this
story is this
today i don't think you can hide i don't
think there's anything like getting off
the hook i don't think i don't think
there's a free lunch fill in whatever
cliche you want
you can't you can't get something for
nothing okay you can't just let all the
criminals out and expect everything to
be hunky-dory you can't just run away
from the mob or try to hide with the mob
or try to placate the mob and assume
that everything's going to be hunky-dory
you can't just run for the hills and
expect that your country will will you
know deal with its problems on its own
and you'll be fine you won't be you
can't get out of that
we have got to stand up we have got to
engage in these political battles we
have to win them we can't there there's
no there's no easy way out of this okay
and if if we don't
if we don't stand up right if we don't
if we don't hold together and stand up
now we'll we'll all fall separately i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show the
leftist culture war against traditional
masculinity continues to gain steam
china is taking a different path that's
today on the ben shapiro show give it a
listen